si vous avez des questions notre équipe est
là pour répondre à toutes vos questions notre site web
le zinedine zidane ce n'était pas rien
contre l'art public c'était plus que euh
ça sentait que ce n'était pas le bon endroit
et ça va être réinstallé
nous prévoyons en fait de  réinstallez-le au musée
3-2-1 zidane est un grand ami du qatar et
il est un excellent modèle pour le monde arabe,
donc l'
une des choses que nous essayons d'enseigner
et d'autonomiser les gens à travers l'art est des faits
sur la vie, donc avec le
sculpture zenedine zidane nous parlerons beaucoup
du stress des athlètes lors des grands
tournois et de l'importance de
traiter les problèmes de santé mentale, etc.